وسط منازل العطلات في طهران على جانب الطريق الثلجي
حيث تم إطلاق النار على الرجل الذي تقول إيران أنه
يجب أن يستمر
عمله أمام زوجته ، حيث قال
العالم النووي الدكتور محسن فخر زاده
إنه مستودع إيران للمعرفة بالقنبلة النووية
، ادعت إسرائيل بينما لم يقل إنهم
كانوا وراء القنبلة النووية.
اغتيال الكثير من الأنقاض يتم
إزالتها هنا ولكن لا يزال بإمكانك رؤية السخام
من الانفجار على المنحنى
والأضرار التي
لحقت بالطريق تحتي ، لا تزال هناك
العديد
من الإصدارات المختلفة للأحداث لما حدث هنا ولكن
شاهد واحد
تحدثنا إليهم يقولون في البداية أنهم سمعوا
انفجار
شاحنة خشبية قالوا إنه انفجرت
هنا ثم حدث تبادل
لإطلاق النار استمر حوالي
ثماني إلى عشر دقائق ، يمكنك أن ترى
هنا الأضرار التي لحقت بالجانب
بسبب الرصاص  من البستان القريب من المواقع التي
يمكن أن تكون قريبة
من كمين للتكنولوجيا المنخفضة على الرغم من أن
مسؤولي الأمن الإيرانيين يخبرون
وسائل الإعلام الحكومية أن هذه
كانت مؤامرة ذات تقنية عالية
مدفع رشاش آلي يعمل بالذكاء الاصطناعي للتعرف على الوجوه يتم التحكم فيه عبر الأقمار الصناعية ، حيث
تصطدمت طلقاته المزيفة
عندما نزل من سيارته المضادة للرصاص ،
وهو أحد الأسباب العديدة المقدمة
لانقطاع الأمن في هذه
المياه
المنعزلة الأنيقة ، قال نجل فخرزاد لوسائل الإعلام الحكومية ، إن
والده تجاهل تحذيرات من
التفاصيل الأمنية الخاصة به في اليوم السابق
قال والدي إنه كان لديه فصل
يقول الابن إنه لا يستطيع التدريس
افتراضيًا واجتماعًا مهمًا حتى
لا يتمكنوا من إقناعه بالعودة
عميقاً داخل وزارة الدفاع يوم الأحد
لقد تذكروه
مرة أخرى على أعلى المستويات بين
منتقدو إيران بصوت عالٍ وأعلى صوتًا السؤال:
هل هذه الهفوة الأمنية الأخرى
تجعل السباق نحو سلاح نووي محتمل
فكرة جيدة
أم أسوأ ، تقول إيران رسميًا إنها
لا تريد القنبلة
لكن برلمانها طالب الأسبوع الماضي
إيران بتخصيب اليورانيوم إلى 20
في  الأسابيع الأولى من إدارة بايدن
التي يمكن أن تجعل السلاح أقرب كثيرًا
ولكن لا تزال هناك نسختان من إيران
كليهما قليلاً  مرئي هنا
، لقد تضررت بشدة من العقوبات وتريد التحدث
أو قاومت وسترد ، نعلم
أن حملتنا تعمل لأن
الإيرانيين الآن يشيرون بشدة
إلى رغبتهم في العودة إلى برقية التفاوض
لتخفيف العقوبات
عن النظام الإسرائيلي إذا شعر بذلك.
يمكن أن
تستمر في تنفيذ أعمال إرهابية ،
سيدفع الإيرانيون ثمنًا لا داعي له
، فالطريقة الوحيدة لإيقاف
هذه الأعمال الإرهابية بالنسبة
للإرهابيين يدفعون ثمنًا
لا يستحق ذلك ، ولا يساورني شك في أن
الإيرانيين سيردون
إيران كانت هنا  قبل الكثير ، حيث
يشهد متحف السيارات المنفجرة هذا على
جميع طرازات بيجو التي تعود إلى
العصور ، اغتيل جميع العلماء النوويين
في سعي إيران لما تقول إنه
تكنولوجيا نووية سلمية
تحتاجها إلى جانب احتياطياتها النفطية الضخمة ،
وقد لا نعرف أبدًا ما هي المعرفة التي
هلكت معها  fakhrazaday أو ما هو
التأثير الذي سيحدث على منتقدي إيران
على الصقور
الذين يدعون أن الأمر قد يكون على بعد
أربعة أشهر فقط.
om صفقات أسلحة نووية محتملة
قد جاء جميع القتلة من العلماء
وذهبوا ، لكن التوتر المتصاعد الذي
يواجه جو بايدن مهمة دبلوماسية ضخمة للتخفيف
في غضون أشهر قليلة أمامه حوالي 40
يومًا لبنائه.